traffic tickets divorce bankruptcy for
all cases that might lend a person in
court American courts play a critical
role in the u.s. justice system by
interpreting making and holding laws so
how do they work well power is shared
between the federal government and state
governments state courts are allowed to
hear most cases like broken contracts
family disputes and robberies but
federal courts only handle certain types
of lawsuits like cases that are governed
by the US Constitution at both the state
and federal level there are three levels
of Courts trial courts appellate courts
and state supreme courts state supreme
courts usually have the final say but
some cases can be appealed to the US
Supreme Court the United States Supreme
Court is the highest court in America
and its decisions are binding in every
court across the country